oh hey i'm getting overwhelmed
i can't stop crying before the movie
starts the world premiere of marvel
studios eternals was epic and if you
missed a moment of it don't worry
because you can capture it all right
here presented by lexus
we are live in hollywood
it's the biggest carpet i've been on
gilgamesh
like the revolutionary evolutionary
speak on it how do you prepare for a
role where you're shooting cosmic beams
out of your eyes i gotta know uh a lot
of steering in the mirror and practicing
your laser eyes did you do any actual
research on set maybe take some things
home we won't tell anybody i promise we
won't tell kevin
oh what if i tell you no no no i can't
tell you no we know you have a couple
brothers and a couple siblings what um
was their reaction when you found out
they didn't really think i was gonna get
it i'm sure everybody says this when
they do a movie together but it really
really became a family
mcu well there we go i didn't think it
happened so it's going to be a different
relationship and then so
they told you somebody told you
but how do you you know with you and
richard madden how did you go about
creating this relationship that spans
thousands of years and has that rich
history we know how to push each other's
buttons we know how to make each other
laugh
we can infuriate each other as well at
times so kind of like yeah an old
married couple in many ways here we were
finishing the infinity sag and i was
thinking where do we go from here how do
we continue where do we grow
and chloe came in and told us i'm in awe
of that woman and it was
exciting to come to work every day and
just like to watch her and be a part of
her mind because you become a part of
her mind guys look at the moon
that's so beautiful
you have no idea how much i love her
don't tell my nephews and my knees what
was the hardest part about keeping
everything secret
uh calling up all my enemies and telling
them i'm i'm in a marvel movie i don't
have it look at me now yeah
it was really fun because i got to do a
lot of hand choreography i don't want to
give anything away i don't want to get
killed but like i know a bunch of stuff
you guys i know a lot of stuff i'm not
joking i heard you say once that this
was kind of a coming of age story for
cersei which i think is so interesting
because you know seven thousand years
old what do you think she's already here
but talk to us a little bit more about
you know after seven thousand years she
would have no it turns out there are
still some things for her to learn what
i love about being a part of this
universe is the diversity and the
inclusion and like so people can
recognize that people who look like you
are out here people who who may be
different sizes who love differently who
are we all are inclusive so it's like
it's really great to show that anybody
can be a hero well we want to ask you
more questions but clearly you only know
that you're a guy who works in the
museums it works in the museum there's
nothing wrong there great that's what
i'm running with i can't wait to see
jane working in the museum that's what i
came here for and that's what they did
too marvel studios eternals will be in
theaters on november 5th tickets are
available now
you should do it right now and it's only
in theaters
[Music]
you